All right, let's have a conversation about
economics here.
One of the stories that Donald Trump has been
telling us is that the economy would be way
better off if the Federal Reserve would sort
of help him out with the federal funds rate
decrease the way that they've helped previous
presidents. And Donald Trump has been talking
about this for several years now. The truth
is that both increases and decreases to the
federal funds rate can help out a president
in different ways. Because the logic is that
when you cut the federal funds rate, it makes
it cheaper for banks to borrow money, which
stimulates economic activity, which will then
boost the stock market. But it also increases,
uh, increasingly signals, uh, when you do
an increase, I guess is what I'm trying to
say. It signals that the Fed sees the economy
as strong enough to tolerate an increase,
which can also be liked by trader. So there
are some economic reasons why it is said or
at least historically has been said that decreases
to the federal funds rate, stimulate certain
types of economic spending.
But at the same time increases in the federal
funds rate are meant to signal strength by
the Fed in their opinion of the economy, which
can get people also buying up stocks and running
up the price of the stock market. So the point
is either way there is a mechanism for which
a federal funds rate and move can help the
economy in this sort of superficial ways that
presidents pay attention to. So in any case,
Donald Trump finally got himself a federal
funds rate decrease on August 1st and stocks
crashed. Looking at the Dow Jones, you'll
see that upon the Fed's announcement of the
rate cut stocks were down about 3% at the
time of this filming today. Intraday, the
Dow is down almost 600 additional points.
And there are three things that I want to
talk about here. Trump's response to this
rate cuts more generally as mechanisms for
influencing the economy.
And then what is really the most important
thing here, which is Donald Trump's tariffs.
So let's start with the first issue. Donald
Trump, after begging for rate cuts and getting
one and it not boosting stocks. And in fact,
coinciding with the decrease came out and
said, well, okay, the reason that this rate
cut didn't work the way I expected was while
the Fed did do a rate cut, they didn't do
a bigger rate cut, which is what I really
wanted. And they also didn't pair the rate
cut with a statement that they're going to
continue doing further cuts. So they're just
not a clear enough signal about how great
the economy is in is going to be. So we don't
really need to talk much more about that.
It's Trump logic, which is also known as antilogic.
I mean, it truly makes no sense whatsoever.
And it is one of these things of Donald Trump
post facto coming up with rationalizations
that nothing beyond a five-year-old or, uh,
a hyperpartisan Republican would fall for.
So then we get to more generally do rate cuts,
actually stimulate the economy. And there's
a really interesting article in the New York
Times which says that lately, no rate cuts
don't really help anymore. In the modern economy.
The normal sort of mechanism is you cut the
federal funds rate and this will lead to Americans
buying more durable goods like cars and such.
It will drop interest rates on mortgages.
So people will start refinancing their homes,
they will lower their payments and have more
money freed up to spend on other stuff. So
it's great for the economy in that way. There
are some other mechanisms, but for the consumer
facing, uh, analysis that that's the primary
analysis, but there's a different modern economy
now that we're in. The reality is the modern
economy doesn't really work this way. People
don't just save, Save, save, and then when
there's a rate cut, go out and do a ton of
spending.
Spending has a much more sort of natural cycle.
And then in addition to that, remember the
bottom 50% of the economy has stagnant wages.
They've had stagnant wages for decades. They
just can't afford it to do much more buying
because the Fed funds rate went down 25 basis
points. So primarily it is a method that ties
into big finance and the run up of stock markets,
which again, only benefit a certain portion
of the economy. Low rates won't do much if
people don't have money. So the long and short
of it is that even this reliance on rate cuts
to jumpstart economies or to prevent recessions.
That's old economic thinking. And of course
it's based on an economic status quo that
was never good for most people anyway of indefinite
growth as the goal. And uh, such a, such a,
a sort of divergence between the benefits
to the top 1% in 10% and 50% and almost nothing
for the bottom 50%.
So that's a bigger conversation to be had.
But then here's the real elephant in the room,
completely missing from Trump getting his
rate cut and stocks crashing. Trump furious
that a 25 basis point rate cut didn't jumpstart
the stock market. Consider that the same day
that the rate funds, uh, re the funds rate
was cut. Trump announced the even more destructive
tariffs, which are terrible for the United
States. Take a look at this. Trump on Twitter,
our representatives have just returned from
China where they had constructive talks having
to do with the future trade deal. We thought
we had to deal with China three months ago,
but sadly China decided to renegotiate the
deal. Prior to signing more recently, China
agreed to buy agricultural products from the
u s in large quantities but did not do so.
Additionally, my printer, my friend president,
she said that he would stop the sale of fentanyl
to the United States.
This never happened and Americans continue
to die. Trade talks are continuing and during
the talks, the u s will start on September
1st putting a small additional tariff of 10%
on the remaining $300 billion of goods and
products coming from China into our country.
This does not include the $250 billion already
tariffed at 25% so the entire conversation
all along Trump so reliant on the federal
funds rate, which increasingly does not generate
the economic reaction that it once used to
or was believed to Trump talking about the
rate decrease wasn't big enough. The messaging
from the Fed wasn't strong enough about how
great the economy is and that there will be
subsequent rate cuts. That entire discussion
was a farce. Trump wanted a rate cut and he
got it and stocks crashed. Well, the problem
is not that the cut wasn't big enough. The
New York Times explains the rate cuts in general
are less connected to immediate stock market
gains, but nowhere in that entire back and
forth is the reality.
That the same day that Trump announced more
tariffs that are terrible for American companies
and Americans at large, the stock market started
to crash and is down. As of right now, it
might be different by the time it closes.
We're filming before the close of the stock
market today, the Dow is down an additional
nearly 600 points as usual. Donald Trump's
propagandizing combined with a just very poor
understanding of basic economics and the totally
missing story of the tariffs ends up with
completely wrong headlines related to what's
happening in our economy and of course people
fall for it and they say yes. The problem
is what Trump says, the problem is not stagnant
wages for 40 years. It's that liberal lefty
biased Federal Reserve that just won't give
Donald Trump a bigger rate cut. Trump is the
victim as usual. One of the things that Trump
has in common with many other authoritarians
regularly framing himself as the victim.
I will be talking much more about this actually
a Wednesday evening, I will be having a live
stream on twitch at 6:30 PM eastern time.
We will be talking about this and many other
economic issues. Follow me there. twitch.tv/david
Pacman and join me Wednesday evening, 6:30
PM eastern.